Disinfectant wipes are great for quick cleanups...
...and keeping your surfaces sterile.
The only problem is that they're overpriced.
So, why not make your own with some household materials?
Grab a roll of paper towels and cut it to fit...
...inside of a small Tupperware container with a serrated knife.
Though it might look a bit ugly at the bottom,...
...but we're more concerned with functionality here.
Pop out the center tube and pull out a bit of the paper towel...
...to serve as a dispensing point.
Make a mixture of half a cup of water...
...and half a cup of rubbing alcohol.
Now, this is enough to party, but if you want it to smell good too,...
...add some drops of essential oil, place the roll into the Tupperware...
...and slowly pour the mixture over it until it's saturated.
Cut a small "x" into the lid and feed the towels through the hole.
Snap it shut and you're all set.
Just keep it nearby to clean up any surfaces...
...that need some quick sanitation.